hey youtubers it's Charlie there's gonna
be my Gotham episode 4 video we finally
got to meet Michael Chiklis and we found
a little bit more about what Theo's
planning for the city something that may
remind you from a quarter Valis
storyline also really interesting fact
today in fictional history Batman fought
the Joker for the first time the first
issue he appeared in was Batman number
one but you remember Batman started in
Detective Comics he didn't start in
Batman so happy Batman vs ocher day
today is also like the flash of two
worlds day but that's only on TV not in
the comics so let's do top five WTF
moments and then I'll explain some of
the new characters from the comics it
kind of kind of what they're doing with
the court eval storyline they're just
they're changing a few things careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet
here we go starting with number five
meet and Samuel Barnes new captain
played by Michael Chiklis he's an
awesome actor I love that he's on the
show if you really want to watch like an
awesome cop drama with Michael Chiklis
watch the shield that was on FX a long
time ago as we meet him in this episode
he's not much of a character yet like
we've only just seen brief bits of him
we don't really know what's going on
underneath the surface he's more of like
a really punchy walking megaphone just
like yelling at people pick that up I'm
gonna kick the out of you if you
break the law
villains are rising this season of
course the police are going to have to
match that so this episode was kind of
like the rise of the police and they
actually kind of strayed into
Untouchables territory if you haven't
seen it it's this amazing film about
Eliot Ness going after Al Capone Al
Capone's played by Robert De Niro Kevin
Costner plays Eliot Ness and Sean
Connery kind of plays an older version
of Detective Gordon during the film
there's this montage where they go and
they put their team together like Alka
Al Capone seems untouchable so they need
this awesome team to take him down when
they're at the academy it's kind of like
when Andy Garcia shows up during
Untouchables
he's like the crack shot rookie from the
Academy like all these people that they
just lined up like you're way too smart
to be here what are you what are you
doing in the police so yeah I got a
little silly went a little over the top
but I love what they're doing with the
Nathaniel Barnes character I think he's
gonna be a lot more entertaining to
watch when we learn more about him on
the number 4 though meet silver st.
cloud
Bruce's special new friend if it wasn't
plainly obvious they're just trying to
present Bruce with Sophie's Choice is he
going to choose the Catwoman path is he
going to choose the high society silver
saying
cloud paths maybe Silver's gonna be
worse for him the cat woman who is an
actual criminal so that's saying a lot
if you're worse than an actual criminal
she seems relatively harmless so I'm
really interested to see how complicit
she is in Theo's plans the misdirect is
to think that just because she's a child
she's innocent which is not the case
I mean we've met Catwoman we know she's
totally not innocent kids in Gotham can
be every bit as crazy as the adults
shout out for poison ivy in the comics
silver st. cloud showed up in 1977 in
Detective Comics number 470 she wasn't
much of a character then she was around
for a Hugo Strange storyline and then
went away for a long time they brought
her back a couple times that weren't
particularly memorable but her biggest
storyline lately has been widening Geyer
that wasn't super recent that was
actually Kevin Smith's Batman story it's
that that was a while ago so for the
most part I'm actually totally cool with
them changing her character from the
comics she's not one of those big a-list
characters she totally fits in with this
court of owls storyline so when you
think of silver st. cloud yeah she's
kind of like sugar I think of it as a
metaphor that Theo is using the sugar to
hide the taste of the poison he's trying
to either win over or neutralize Bruce
on the number three though Theo
versus the penguin so this is actually
really interesting scene where he
reveals that big cityscape with some of
his grand plans for Gotham similar to
what was going on with the Arkham City
storyline where it's like we're gonna
rebuild got them the way we want it to
be but in this instance it's a lot
closer to what was going on during court
of owls but they changed a few things
because during court of owls it was
Bruce Wayne that wanted to revitalize
Gotham so he presents Lincoln March who
is the mayor of Gotham at the time with
this plan for redesigning Gotham he
shows him a model of Gotham with a bunch
of new buildings so they're twisting
that making it more of a sinister thing
but the whole idea is who is going to
control the future of Gotham penguin of
course is kind of funny he's one of
those characters that just can't catch a
break no matter how powerful he thinks
he is supposed to be the king of Gotham
but he can barely control his minions on
top of that Theo's reaction to him was
just so awesome it's just like oh you
think you're the king of Gotham how cute
is that
let me show you my favorite reality show
I mean I really didn't like that line
that was it was kind of cheesy but you
get the idea he's trying to control the
person who thinks he is controlling
everyone else he's supposed to be goth
final boss form so is Bruce and all the
other characters muscle-up they have to
defeat all the smaller villains til they
make it to the final boss James frames
totally amazing as a villain I've never
seen a villain performance of his that I
didn't like but the only thing I'm not
gonna get on board with is his American
accent that he's using in this it's just
too weird I'm not really sure why it's
not okay for him to have a British
accent just because that feels a lot
more natural coming out of his mouth but
but I'll give him some time made me you
know maybe I'll warm up to it on the
number two the Riddler and Miss Kringle
so this was mostly fun from a comedy
perspective but I just I want the actor
Corey Michael Smith that plays the
Riddler
to wear this t-shirt that says the
Riddler is my co-pilot because he keeps
hallucinating that other personality now
the after said that it's not a split
personality so I don't know exactly how
they're gonna explain it but he is
definitely not going anywhere like
that's gonna continue to be a thing so
if you thought that was a lot of fun
like him just being crazy with himself
they're gonna continue to develop that
and as nice as regular nygma is none of
this bodes well for Miss Kringle who is
just like traded one crazy person for
another you have to feel a little bad
for her even though it's nice to see
them together I feel like they would be
a good fit
so maybe if she becomes a villain
eventually there'd be a lot of fun but I
don't think they're taking her in that
direction the Riddler has had a lot of
assistance in the past but none of them
have ascended to Harley Quinn levels so
yay for the two of them somebody get
them the number of an abuse hotline
because Miss Kringle is probably I need
to call it in a couple episodes finally
on to my number one WTF moment more
abuse
Alfred hits the cat there are very few
things you can do that are worse than
abusing an animal you have to feel so
bad for her this scene here with the
fire hydrant on the street is just her
self-esteem pouring onto the pavement
just sadness everywhere what is the
whole reason for this atrocity to be
committed what is the purpose of this
well mostly it's the narrative
challenging the Catwoman to make a
decision what she's gonna do about Bruce
do you want to be with it like do you
want to be his friend do you want to be
romantically involved with him or do you
want to have nothing to do with him at
all she's gonna have to pick this is
West Side Story all over again so of
course she's going to choose Bruce and
she's going to challenge Alfred she's
gonna stick up for herself say no no I
can do what I want I can be friends with
whoever I want to be Selina Kyle and
Bruce will always be way more
interesting than Bruce with other
character
silver st. cloud is just temporary so if
you're like really bummed out the
Catwoman got kicked to the curb she'll
be back with a vengeance let me know in
the comments though there were like a
couple twists in the plot that were
super obvious they telegraphed
especially with Bruce and silver st.
cloud and Catwoman how do you guys feel
about that like do you get upset when
it's too obvious or did you kind of pick
up on the idea that they wanted it to be
silly
sometimes I get an idea that the
characters on this TV show know they're
in a comic book TV show so they act like
comic book characters would which
technically would be accurate but most
TV shows try to play a little bit more
real it can be kind of confusing what
other comic book shows play it straight
like their comic book shows where the
characters know they're in a comic book
like imagine every single character
acting like Cisco that would be kind of
bad Cisco on the flash is funny because
he's one of the few characters that
acknowledges that comic books exist if
every character did that it'd be
terrible like you have to have
characters reacting to the ridiculous
character but I am really excited to see
Michael Chiklis kick the out of the
penguin because that's who they're going
after first more animal abuse on Gotham
so here's the deal new episode of the
flash tonight it is gonna be crazy make
sure you watch it it's called the flash
of two worlds
they are totally going full-on comic
book there's gonna be some iconic comic
book moments during the episode if
you've ever read the flash of two worlds
that was just the first time in the
comics the Barry Allen met Jay Garrick I
will also be starting a new round of the
reverse flash ring giveaway so a lots of
stuff happening tonight just in case you
guys haven't seen it there are a whole
bunch of trailers that I posted in the
last couple days you can click here for
a bunch of new footage from air on the
flash and you can click here for the
daredevil season 2 trailer with the
first look at the Punisher thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you